bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle édition du 7 8
week-end votre émission vous le savez
dédié à l'actualité culture loisirs et
sports de la semaine et ce pendant 26
minutes
au cours de cette édition nous parlerons
nature avec laurent carle directeur
adjoint du centre horticole
d'enseignement et de promotion le chef
du tremblay sur mauldre à quelques
heures de la fête de la nature et de
l'animation parole de jardiniers mais
également d'improvisation théâtrale et
du royaume du jeu avec les représentants
de la maison de la jeunesse et de la
culture des clayes sous bois
mais tout d'abord vous le savez
peut-être et vous l'avez suivi six ans
notre antenne ce lundi se tenait la
finale nationale du trophée
d'improvisation culture et diversité
parmi les cinq villes participantes les
collégiens de trappes défendez les
couleurs de leur commune pour la
quatrième année une finale marquée par
la présence inattendue du président de
la république
aurélien depuis si elodie mois
avec brad de lacharrière parce que c'est
lui qui a lancé cette ville de lille gfr
rabat aussi avec gmail de mouche parce
qu'il y a déjà convaincu de venir
assister à un match d'improvisation de
la femme l'avait promis à trappes en
février dernier et il l'a fait françois
hollande était lundi au théâtre le
comédia à paris pour remettre le trophée
d'impro culture et diversité
un championnat national intercollèges
d'improvisation théâtrale cinq villes
participer au tournoi
bordeaux lille rochefort trappe et cette
année paris entrée dans la compétition
venus en invité surprise ce sont des
mains du président de la république que
les jeunes gagnants bordelais se sont vu
remettre le trophée d'impro 2014 et il y
a quatre ans par la fondation culture et
diversité et jamel debbouze parrain de
l'événement qui a lui-même fait ses
premiers pas de comédien grâce au
théâtre d'impro
tout a changé la culture à mu et où tous
les gamins les gamins sont plus du tout
les mêmes
ils ont une autre énergie ils ont
d'autres problématiques ils ont d'autres
sujets de conversation et j'en doute
rapport à tous donc sur la patinoire on
l'entend on voit bien les exorcistes ou
donc si oui juste d'entendre un peu et
je vous assure que c'est impressionnant
on en a une étude sociologique marrante
un match d'impro
de plus avoir honte de moi depuis avoir
peur des autres
de plus être dans le jugement
constamment de ce que j'ai thème de ce
qu'on pouvait penser ça va apporter une
prise de confiance certains peut-être
excessives parfois mais mais c'est vrai
que ça m'a donné
ça m'a donné du courage jeu m'a donné de
la force d'être applaudi par des gens je
vous jure que ça ça me remonte le moral
et peu importe ce qui se passe chez vous
s'aguerrisse et salvateur session
salvateur c'est aussi ce que pense la
nouvelle génération pour qui le théâtre
d'improvisation est un moyen de sortir
de l'échec scolaire
je sais que si l'un pro existerait pas
dans mon collège
j'aurais sans doute décroché l'école
franchement ça fait plaisir surtout de
savoir que dans quelques années ce sera
tous les jeunes de trappes qui feront ça
c'est larmes aux yeux quand on se dit
que c'est à l'horizon de nous ça ça
reste impressionnant c'est la meilleur
moyen de représenter les jeunes de
france avec la collaboration de la
mythique compagnie d'improvisation
théâtrale déclic théâtre reconnu à
trappes pour ses actions en faveur de
l'éducation artistique et culturelle
auprès des collégiens le trophée d'impro
culture et diversité a pour objectif
d'étendre au niveau national fort
pratique artistique qui est très
important justement c'est ça c'est que
ça devienne une pratique culturelle et
artistique et
et pas seulement un truc qu'on fait pour
rigoler ça fait très longtemps qu'il
existe des d'impro ça fait très
longtemps qu'on travaille en
improvisation théâtrale avec les enfants
avec les ados et avec les adultes en
professionnel en amateur et c'est bien
que enfin le monde de la culture
commence à se dire que c'est vraiment de
l'art c'est vraiment de la culture c'est
vraiment des productions artistiques
intéressante parce qu'elles sont
éphémères et que c'est ça qui est
chouette et du coup la présence du
président de la république aujourd'hui
c'était aussi une reconnaissance
institutionnelle du match d'impro dans
le cadre de l'éducation artistique et
culturelle
on est en train de travailler avec le
ministère de la culture le ministère de
l'éducation nationale pour cette
reconnaissance donc c'est quand même un
grand pas pour nadja l'impro cette année
le président de la république deux
ministres présents ce lundi celui de
l'éducation et de la culture en effet un
grand pas pour l'improvisation théâtrale
qui forte de cette reconnaissance
institutionnelle invite de nouvelles
villes à rejoindre le trophée d'impro et
il va y avoir également un superbe match
d'improvisation juniors cette fois ci ce
samedi à la mjc des clayes-sous-bois à
quelques heures de cette soirée de
l'après-midi royaume du jeu le directeur
de la mjc yves le baut et nec est
présent sur ce plateau et vous êtes
accompagné de stéphane castel
administrateurs et improvisateur de la
mjc bonjour à tous les deux mais je
voulais être là donc ce samedi match
d'improvisation aux clayes-sous-bois
est-ce qui va opposer la compagnie
créole à la compagnie d un profiteroles
c'est ça il est tout à fait tout d'abord
merci nous accueillir sommes très
heureux d'être ici
donc effectivement c'est
donc samedi il y aura ce match
d'improvisation qui va opposer deux
équipes
tout ça se déroule de manière très
amicale mais stéphane va vous expliquer
tout ça en détail puisque illégalement
improvisateurs avant d'être
administrateur mais nous sommes une zone
heureux d'avoir accueilli stephan cette
année et alors du coup ce match
d'improvisation stéphane comment comment
cela s'est déroulé alors c'est il faut
bien penser que ce sont des juniors
demain donc c'est un peu un match
particulier pour eux puisque ils ont
entre 15 et 18 ans et il est ce sont
deux mi temps de 45 minutes sur des
sujets très variés puisque c'est de
l'improvisation tirés au hasard par l'
arbitre au milieu qui se fait souvent
sifflé c'est le seul sport on a le droit
de siffler d'arbitrage et sans risque d'
avertissement rien tout le monde déteste
larbitre même le public et surtout le
public est là et juniors vont s'en
donner à coeur joie et on espère bien
sûr que les clients devons gagner et
dans les scénarii des clercs la
compagnie déclic que je représente est
bon on va pas faire du chemin exactement
est alors du coup sûr ces matchs d'impro
dans l'impression c'est de plus en plus
à la mode en tout cas que cela plaît de
plus en plus aux jeunes
j'espère on est là pour ça et on est là
pour initier les jeunes à participer à
cette activité à aimer et à faire aimer
cette activité-là qui on connaît le
théâtre classique sur scène je me
déplace mais là c'est un contexte
complètement particulier vous ne verrez
pas de spectacle d'improvisation
identique même si c'est la même équipe
ce qui est très rare déjà même ça peut
être déjà le même sens propre puisque
c'est elle son unique à la fois à sa
personnalité
en plus chacun sa personnalité les
acteurs ne sont pas les mêmes donc c'est
très très unique et très très
fantastique de participer assad monter
ça être dans les coulisses pour les
jeunes et pour les soutenir
comment pourrait-on résumer justement un
match d'improvisation c'est un petit peu
l' équilibre entre l'humour la
créativité puis le naturel en même temps
c'est un fait ça c'est quand même
travailler vos posts le reste je
travaille beaucoup
en amont c'est pas que du naturel c'est
aussi beaucoup travaillé on nous donne
des techniques pour savoir comment
réagir
on fait beaucoup d'imagination vous en
doutez donc c'est pour ça qu'on fait ça
et est alors du coup c'est donc un match
qui va se dérouler à partir de 20h30 ce
samedi ça va clôturer une belle journée
je si j'ose dire
yves le bouillonnec puisque tout l'après
midi il va y avoir la deuxième édition
du royaume du jeu qui va se passer
évidemment aussi à l'espace philippe
noiret tout à fait alors je vais
simplement juste complété par rapport au
match d'improvisation théâtrale puisque
par rapport à la mjc nous sommes en
partenariat avec la libye la ligue
d'improvisation théâtrale des yvelines
et dans ce projet ce qui nous intéresse
aussi tout particulièrement c'est le
fait que les jeunes participent
également à l'organisation
donc il y à la phase match match
d'improvisation il ya également aussi
commencé dans tout ce spectacle il ya
une phase de préparation et là aussi les
jeunes
l'ensemble du groupe est associé à cette
préparation donc je je tenais à la
rappeler puisque c'est important
effectivement c'est ce n'est pas juste
le spectacle que voilà autant de public
et donc du coup avant ce spectacle bal
et les habitants des clayes-sous-bois
pourront découvrir ce cette deuxième
édition du royaume du jeu tout à fait
donc également dans cette même logique
par rapport au projet de la mjc projet
associatif de l'association association
d'éducation populaire avec notamment
cette volonté des masses et
d'émancipation l'émancipation des jeunes
également des adultes
l'idée est venue il y à l'année dernière
donc il ya un an
actuellement maintenant eric un jeune
adhérent de la mjc nous a proposé a
proposé à l'association
2 pourquoi ne pas monter une après midi
autour du jeu mais à l'origine est comme
ça le concept c'est de pouvoir venir de
façon libre jouer à différents jeux de
stratégie jeux de rôles etc puis refaire
un petit peu son monde de l'imaginaire
c'est un peu ça on essaie de s'unir
autour des tables de jeu tout à fait
stephen je pense que tu as eu l'occasion
de participer à cet événement l'année
dernière oui on vous avez vous avez
rencontré d'ailleurs être effacées lente
mais votre votre chaîne de division
m'avait interviewé et donc j'étais là un
peu à côté ni tôt puisque je n'étais pas
encore administrateur de la mjc mais je
veux participer à cette action etc
et c'est d'autant plus valorisant pour
un jeune qui avait 17 ans à l'époque de
monter un projet gros comme ça avec une
collaboration de plusieurs associations
machiavel fantaisie ribambelle et la mjc
une grosse organisation
plein de gens bénévoles derrière ces on
a reçu beaucoup beaucoup de monde s'est
alors du coup sûr cette édition du
royaume du jeu on a l'impression qu'il
ya toujours un besoin d' imaginaires
chez les yvelinois puisque on reste
évidemment les yvelines où on a besoin
toujours de s'évader un petit peu plus
je pense qu on est toujours restés
enfants dans notre tête et qu'on a
besoin de ce retour à l'enfance et c'est
pour ça qu'on dit le royaume du gc pour
les grands et pour les petits et ne pas
que pour le petit pas que pour les
enfants on accueille tous les publics de
7 77 ans comme on dit mais moi je
préfère dire de 3 à 99 ans c'est
beaucoup plus large et large exactement
et il va y avoir je pense des joueurs
chevronnés comme vous je me souviens que
vous maîtrisiez très très bien l'art des
des jeux de rôles l'année dernière bah
oui mais c'est n'est pas que pour moi
est que pour le joueur chevronné parce
que les joueurs chevronnés ils vont
aller dans un jeu et voir que le jeu
moi je me souviens une fois j'avais fait
que un jeu pendant toute une après midi
c'est un petit peu dommage
il faut découvrir d'autres jeux allaient
faire des petits jeux qu'on connaît pas
assez voilà ce royaume du jeu c'est
évidemment je pense et le boédec de le
meilleur moyen de passer aussi un bon
moment en famille essayait de voir les
parents jouent avec les enfants et de
multiplier les les tables oui tout à
fait là on est bien évidemment dans un
esprit de convivialité de partage et
l'ensemble des participants sont là pour
se faire plaisir avant tout on a
également mis en place pour essayer de
d'associer les parents également les
jeunes on a mis en place un espace
d'accueil pour les tout petits et on
travaille on travaille on est en
collaboration en partenariat avec une
association locale qui est l'association
de tourbillon qui va venir proposer des
jeux pour les tout-petits et en
parallèle on aura aussi d'autres jeux
ben du coup pour les ados pour les plus
grands et pour les plus grands
très bien donc si vous voulez aller
découvrir ce cette deuxième édition du
royaume du jeu rendez vous à l'espace
philippe le ray aux clayes-sous-bois
partir de 13 heures ce samedi et pour la
soirée du match d'improvisation à partir
de 20h30 merci à tous les deux d'être
passés sur le 7-8 week-end on suivra ça
de très près et vous ce week end le
soleil s'était installé 1 sur saint
quentin en yvelines vous avez dû le
remarquer avec des températures proches
des 20
5° le barbecue était de sortie à la base
de loisirs claire combier à manger
quelques grillades pour nous il n'y a
plus aucune place sur la grille du
barbecue la glacière et plein pas un
nuage aux environs tous les ingrédients
pour une première après midi au soleil
réussi semblent réunies et bio n'est pas
les argents les autres il ya tellement
ya beaucoup plaident l'espace et voilà
les enfants sont là ils sont de l'espace
pour jouer sont tranquilles pour leur
vie peuvent courir
chacun ramène à manger et à boire au
menu brochettes de poulet saucisses
merguez
tout est prêt à être grillé quelques
arbres plus loin dans cette famille
d'origine malgache les hommes s'occupent
des grillades les femmes préparent les
salades
voilà c'est du coup les bains en fait
c'est déjà macérer depuis ce matin et de
la sauce et avec une touche de miel pour
l'aspect sucré en famille entre amis le
loupe jamais l'occasion de profiter du
soleil sur saint quentin en yvelines et
évidemment après intel barbecue la
musique permet de continuer la fête sous
le soleil
et il compte bien danser jusqu'à la
tombée de la nuit
et si vous avez la main verte vous
pourrez découvrir ce samedi également la
fête de la nature j'en parlais dans les
titres de cette émission au chef le
centre horticole d'enseignement et de
promotion au tremblay sur mauldre est
pour en parler de cet événement laurent
car le directeur adjoint du chef est
présent sur le plateau du site week-end
bonjour à vous bonjour merci d'être là
alors tout d'abord la fête de la nature
j'ai l'impression si un peu une
découverte de la biodiversité dans son
ensemble voilà alors bros ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que la fête de la nature
c'est un événement qui met en avant bien
sûr l'environnement et la nature
ça a été créé en 2007 donc ça fait déjà
quelques quelques années
l'objectif bien sûr c'est de célébrer la
nature et c'est à l'origine du comité
français de l'union internationale de
conservation de la nature se déroule en
général sur cinq jours de manifestations
gratuites
ça touche bien sûr des milliers de
manifestations au niveau du national et
bien sûr sur tout le territoire français
et alors du coup pendant ces quelques
jours donc je sais que c'était du 21 au
25 mai là c'est ce temps fort que vous
organisez demain ce samedi 24 mai on va
pouvoir aussi pour les visiteurs
découvrir notamment aussi le travail de
vos élèves
donc pendant la visite exactement alors
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que la
thématique de la fête de la nature cette
année c'est herbes folles jeunes pousses
et vieilles branches et donc c'est
autour de cette thématique que nous
avons réalisé des événements des
animations des jeux pour que justement
les familles puissent venir découvrir
d'une part notre établissement mais
également bain les différentes
animations et découvertes tout autour de
du paysage et de l'environnement
justement autour de ces animations
l'idée c'est d'être didactique
pédagogique pour peut-être aussi inciter
les visiteurs à devenir un petit peu
jardiniers en quelque sorte non alors
non seulement les inciter à devenir
jardinier mais également à les
sensibiliser sur l'importance de la
nature dans la nature dans les espaces
naturels mais également en ville en zone
périurbaine et c'est vrai qu'à chacun
d'entre nous est bon on peut être amené
à pouvoir protéger d'une part la faune
mais également la flore et à côté et
parallèlement à cela et ben on met en
place par exemple des maisons à insectes
pour lesquels les bains il ya le ca fait
des petits refuges très intéressant pour
les insectes de nous de nos villes
sensibiliser également par rapport à la
protection de la biodiversité intense
pour les pour la faune pardon que pour
la flore avec une animation sur les
abeilles et donc on nous nous aurons un
rucher et un apiculteur qui viendra se
déplacera pour pouvoir expliquer le
fonctionnement d'une ruche les abeilles
la pollinisation et cetera l'importance
de ces aspects là alors il ya un atelier
qui maquille massé interpellées
notamment la cuisine des plantes
sauvages qu'on va pouvoir découvrir ce
samedi ou encore
construire un réseau d'arrosage
automatique des choses vraiment plus que
pratique en fin de compte très pratique
pour lesquelles les personnes une fois
rentrées chez elles pourront les mettre
en oeuvre et les mettre en application
pour en revenir sur l'utilisation des
désherbants sauvage on pense assez
souvent aux orties les l'urti kaddioui
cas de son nom latin et c'est vrai que
ben c'est méconnu quand on est touché
ben c'est urticants donc ça pique donc
on n'y touche peu mais parallèlement et
dont on peut en faire des ex
d'excellents plats à partir du moment où
on connaît deux des petites recettes qui
du coup permettent un certain marc miton
de pouvoir mettre en oeuvre des très
bons repas et alors à côté de cette fête
de la nature vous participez aussi aux
paroles du jardinier cette animation
aussi très importante au cours de
l'année il y aura notamment la visite du
parc qui fait 21 et tard si je ne me
trompe pas et surtout quelque chose
d'assez original la visite de la
roseraie alors en quoi ça consiste
nous avons la chance d'être
effectivement sur 21 hectares avec 10
hectares d'espacés paysagers qui permet
de servir de plateau technique pour nos
formations paysage heures mais également
10 hectares d'espacés naturels qui nous
servent de base pour plateau technique
pour l'information par rapport à
l'environnement sur ces 21 ha nous avons
une roseraie de 1800 pieds de rosiers
pour lesquelles en ce moment grâce au
beau temps est à la pluie et ben c'est
en pleine floraison donc c'est
magnifique de beauté mais également de
senteurs voilà donc les jeunes en cette
année participé à la réfection de la
roseraie dons qui sont énormément
impliqué justement pour la rendre plus
belle pour apporter des mobiliers pour
que les personnes une fois qu'elles
seront sur place puisse vraiment
profiter pleinement de cette très belle
rejoint leur et du coup il y as combien
de d'espèces de plantes d'arbres au sein
de votre parquet alors sur l'arboretum
nous avons plus de 700 taxus qui
correspond de fait un bon nombre très
intéressant et très riche en terme de
diversité paysagère avec un arboretum
d'un peu plus ancien cas 30 ans est un
peu plus jeune qui a une quinzaine
d'années et pour terminer j'ai vu
qu'aussi dans les ateliers proposés pour
cette animation parole de jardiner
un atelier de d'empotage rempotage donc
ça c'est aussi quelque chose de très
pratique encore une fois tout à fait
l'idée si vous voulez nous avons une
petite serre de production et pour
lesquels demain à l'occasion de notre
journée et ben on pourra vendre quelques
plans et les personnes qui
souhaiteraient venir rempoter
directement viendront avec leur jardine
leurs jardinières et on pourra faire non
seulement de la pédagogie sur comment
rempoter de fait ils vont repartir chez
eux avec clé en main une très belle
jardinières fleuries à utiliser prête à
être utilisée très bien donc si vous
voulez évidemment à voir tous ces bons
conseils rendez vous au chef du tremblay
sur mauldre ce samedi dès 9 heures merci
beaucoup merci à vous le week-end
dernier fakir tours de cartes ou encore
apparition s'étaient emparés de l'espace
de covile à voisins le bretonneux
l'association de magie les 78 tours
tenait son deuxième festival et durant
trois jours le public a pu découvrir les
nombreuses facettes de la magie jérémy
et brasse et julien leroy les mamans
et je l'aimé ou encore qu'est ce qui se
passe papa et maman semble plus la
préface
alors je sens quelque chose
2 3 4
ça
on l'a fait
voisins le bretonneux les magiciens des
78 tours font le show et ravissent les
jeunes et les moins jeunes j'aime
beaucoup la magie depuis ma tendre
enfance et bon j'habite le 78 et puis
j'ai vu ce festival
je me suis dit pourquoi pas aller voir
c'est marrant fin on comprend rien aux
trucs et enfin on a impressionné qu'est
ce qui te plaît dans la journée dans les
tours de magie
alors quel est le tour de magie qui te
plaît le plus alors justement moi j'ai
dit j'ai bien aimé lors du 2e festival
de l'association les 78 tours les
enfants des étoiles plein les yeux
il découvre s'initier à la magie ébahis
par les tours de passe passe
ils ont envie de connaître les secrets
de cet art mais d'ailleurs comment
devient ton magicien bien il ya pas
vraiment de l'école c'est simplement la
motivation qui va faire que vous serez
un jour magicien aux 78 tours pour
apprendre la magie
donc n'importe qui peut venir nous
rejoindre
il suffit juste de l'avoir de la vente
et et
un petit peu de dextérité et les
magiciens ont un conseil à donner aux
futurs prestidigitateur le plus
compliqué dans un tour de magie
ce n'est pas le tour en lui-même mais
capté l'attention du public
il faut donc raconter une histoire voici
un exemple à le tour en lui-même c'est
pas la partie la plus difficile c'est le
capter l'attention des gens des publics
et de faire monter la dramatisation
comme on appelle ça c'est à dire créer
une tension qui va mener jusqu'à au
final du tour et qui va se déclencher
applaudissements
petite touche d'humour ce week-end
montigny accueillait les championnats
départementaux de tir à l'arc en
extérieur et au milieu des 160 archers
isabelle patrice et leurs deux enfants
décrochent leurs flèches en famille
portraits réalisés avec l'air comme si
chacun a sa spécialité il partage
désormais une passion commune pour la
cible dans la famille rampon l'histoire
est désormais faite d'arcs et de flèches
et c'est d'ailleurs vincent le fils qui
est arrivé le premier sur le pas de tir
et son père patrice a vite suivi sa
trajectoire en m'accompagnant sur les
concours parce que sinon je pouvais pas
je pouvais pas y aller donc pu
m'accompagner sur les concours plus
remarqué qu'au final c'était peut-être
pas si mal que ça donc à présent essayer
sollicité par l'entraîneur de la famille
alexandra aurélie décoche ses premières
flèches il y a un an et demi et elle a
vite trouvé le centre de la cible assez
rapidement en fait c'est malheureusement
maintenant il ya une stagnation qui est
un petit peu difficile à accepter c'est
compliqué de gérer la défaite
il s'entraîne désormais deux fois par
semaine et essaient de participer
ensemble aux compétitions
mais évidemment sur le pâtir la rivalité
parfois omniprésente au sein de la
famille entre vincent patrice et
alexandra aurélie tout le monde veut
réussir le meilleur score vincent et moi
et alexandra ont réussi qui elle
s'attire depuis moins longtemps que nous
parce qu'elle a commencé il ya que deux
ans et donc qu'elle voudrait nous
rattraper très rapidement il a un peu de
mal mais ils y arrivent donc bon bah
maintenant y'a plus qu'à continuer il
passera peut-être devant moi
s'ils n'ont pas fait leur meilleur
volley de la saison sur ce championnat
départemental ces quatre archers auront
passé un moment en famille et c'est bien
là l'essentiel
et avant de refermer cette édition comme
d'habitude place à votre agenda du
week-end et trois rendez vous la fête de
la nature tout d'abord ce samedi 24 mai
de 9h à 17h au chef au tremblay sur
mauldre vous pourrez apprendre à
cuisiner des plantes sauvages vous
réalisez vous
propres compositions florales il y aura
également un match d'improvisation
théâtrale vous pourrez assister à ce
match junior à la mjc des
clayes-sous-bois entre la compagnie
créole et les uns profiteroles début des
hostilités à 20h30 et en sport il y aura
du rugby ce dimanche 16e de finale
retour du championnat de france de
fédérale 3 un match qui pourrait devenir
historique pour plaisir qui reçoit
chartres au stade robert barran et en
cas de succès le club validerait son
billet pour la fédérale 2 coup d'envoi à
15 heures c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite
un excellent week-end sur télé fil à
très bientôt